[Music]
humans are now living longer than ever
before in just a century American life
expectancy has gone from 47 to 79 years
in one century today's scientists are
growing hearts in the lab creating
organs with 3d bioprinter x' bodily
organs and eliminating cells that
shorten life eliminating them will this
new technology yield another dramatic
increase in life expectancy is it a good
idea that's a question that some people
are asking so let me introduce our
guests our first guest is the director
of regenerative medical research and
director of the Center for cell and
organ biotechnology at the Texas Heart
Institute in Houston
please welcome Doris Taylor our next
guest is the director of the Robert and
Arlene cogut Center on Aging at the Mayo
Clinic and no abhira foundation
professor of aging research please
welcome James L Kirkland
our next guest is a novelist a blogger a
syndicated columnist a media commentator
and expert in international affairs and
biotechnology bio politbureau Technology
Policy ladies and gentlemen Jaime Metzl
and our final guest for this evening is
the William II William Davis jr. MD
professor of medical ethics and chief of
the division of medical ethics at Weill
Cornell Medical College
please welcome Joseph pins and we're
gonna start with the question what is
biological aging and why should we study
it let me start with you Doris well I
think biologic aging is really a
function of the age of our cells you
know I'm a I'm a I'm a act 20 some days
but my cells no they're not that being
said I think biologic aging is really a
culmination of stress emotional mental
physical parameters that impact every
aspect of our body and including not
just ourselves but our organs and
tissues James I think one of the views
in the field is that there are a number
of processes which determine your
physiologic age or your biologic age as
opposed to your chronological age which
can be quite distinct so when you think
of children they're really quite similar
at a particular chronological age you
know a kid in kindergarten is very much
like another kid in kindergarten and
they view a kid in grade one as being a
lot older than they are almost the same
age as their parents when people are in
their 20s they're becoming a little more
distinct but they may be at the same
level of University and
and but there there are some differences
appearing when you get to people in
their 80s and 90s because I'm amongst
other things I'm a geriatrician I see
these people you know many of us are
approaching that age and our parents and
grandparents have been through this
there are some 85 year olds who are out
there playing 36 holes of golf a day and
others who have 20 different conditions
and are in 30 different drugs so
biologic age and chronological age
diverge quite a bit as you get older and
really what biological age predisposes
to are the major age-related chronic
diseases the highest risk factor for
having a heart attack for example is
your age and it's more specifically your
biological age biological age well at
the fundamental level there are you you
can bin or group these processes in
various different ways but one way I
simplistically like to think of it that
applies across many organisms is a
degree of inflammation of tissues
cellular senescence which we'll probably
talk about a bit later problems with
large molecules like DNA proteins lipids
sugars and also organelles within cells
and then stem and progenitor cell
dysfunction you find these processes are
highly linked to each other you use
drugs at target one you tend to affect
the others or single gene mutations and
they tend to be conserved across many
species although not every process is
conserved in all species all right we'll
come back to that because aging is very
complex and multifactorial it's really
hard there's no standard definition of
what biological age is then we know as
Jim said the different people age at
different rates
we know that different parts of our body
age at different rates and so while
there are these two things chronological
age and biological age one of the big
challenges in this field is to establish
some kind of uniformity for what
biological age is and the reason that's
important is because we're going to talk
about these different types of
interventions but we need to be able to
benchmark what is succeeding and what is
not succeeding and so biological age its
we can understand it conceptually but
really making it real in a way that's
going to allow us to compare different
types of treatment that's the gold
standard and we're not there yet Joe I
think age is not just a biological
construct it's a social construct and
when you start expanding the life cycle
and you start interrupting one person's
life with another life and a sequence of
generational issues I think we're gonna
have a lot to talk about about what it
means for social disruption well I mean
you know you know as a faculty member at
a medical school you know and the
10-year age keeps on going older and
older and older there's a whole cohort
of adjuncts who want my job right so so
that's what happens when you expand the
life expectancy of professors and and
and is that a good thing for the Academy
or is it a good thing for society so I
think I my sense of it is I'm a big fan
of the work that folks are doing here
but I think a useful construct is what
we call fair innings you know that if
somebody has a life that's shortened
because of a premature illness and and
and they're not going to get their full
nine innings we want to you know extend
the life to fair innings but when you
start getting into extra inning games
the next day is really difficult when
you have to play again so I just think
we need to think about the context the
broader context of what when we change
individuals and we change a lot of
individuals what are we doing to the
group what are we doing the society but
that's a really important point about a
social construct cuz absolutely but how
do how do we think about what the social
construct is at the time of the Roman
Empire average life expectancy was 25 as
you said Bill in the introduction 100
years ago it was 47 and everything was
benchmarked against that expectation
it's like in Roman Roman times oh my god
you made it to 40 that was like a huge
accomplishment and so I also think we
have all of these structures that are
just based on this one historic moment
and as things change those structures
will also I think that just quickly I
think there's a question of radical
disruption and how fast can you
accommodate the change and the other
question is who will get the enhancement
well I was just gonna say that I think a
lot of what many of us are trying to do
is
not necessarily extend life for those
extra innings it's to extend health
through those fair innings that that
really the aspects of longevity that we
want to talk about are living healthy
longer as well as you know the kids who
call me and say can you keep my mom
alive or can you the parents who call me
and say can you help my son
right and I totally agree with that but
the title of the session is engineering
immortality right so the you know so I
think we need to understand that that
that there's a there's a kind of a
medical sort of hippocratic you know
intent and then how it's understood
about we're gonna live far longer then
it's true but I mean Doris said in the
green room which isn't actually green
but that death sucks and I think that we
have been socialized to accept death and
I don't think immortality is gonna be
possible for a very long time if ever
we've been socialized to accept death
we've been socialized to define our
lives in relationship to death but
quoting again Doris death sucks
I mean think of all of the wisdom all of
the love all of the poetry everything
that goes away when somebody somebody
dies if we had the opportunity to extend
healthy lifespan I mean all of the
demographic projections suggest that
around 2050 we're gonna start shrinking
again as a global public and we would
need to change social constructs but how
wonderful if people's
if people could meet their great
grandparents and maybe we will have to
you know you lose your tenure at 60 or
70 or whatever but let's solve for that
problem not say that we have this
infrastructure based on our current life
expectancy there for everyone's parents
and grandparents have to die when
there's a lot of extra potential so so
to get more specific to move to another
topic where are we now you guys who are
specialists in this as far as targeting
the aging process the idea in the field
is if we can target fundamental aging
processes can we delay the arc can we
delay prevent or alleviate this
constellation of age-related diseases as
a group instead of targeting these
things one at a time if you cure heart
attacks for exam
you are choosing to die instead a few
months later of Alzheimer's disease or
some cancer it's a whack-a-mole
situation so why not go for these things
as a group as it as a clinician what I'm
worried about is my patients having poor
quality of life having onset of these
age-related diseases that cluster within
individuals if you get one age-related
disease your time to the next one is two
and a half years the one after that is a
year the one after that is six months
they cluster in people and we've all
seen that but we need to target that and
delay it and that's what some of these
drugs do that seem to work in mice maybe
if we can get them to people so I think
that makes sense though endogenous
repair fails and as it fails it doesn't
just fail in your heart then just fail
in your liver it fails everywhere and
part of that is because the capacity for
repair that we have these cells go down
as we age and and those selves the more
hits you take the more you use those
cells
the fewer you have the more likely one
two three four or five set things are
gonna fail I think that's part of it I
think the other thing that happens is
you have damaged cells that don't that
aren't gotten rid of so there's failure
to remove cells you don't necessarily
need to replace them in some instances
there are damage cells that don't get
removed they can become cancerous they
can produce things the senescent cells
very small numbers of them produce
factors that cause widespread systemic
dysfunction so if only one in 10,000 of
your cells is senescent after the when
they're transplanted you get in mice you
cause frailty for six months you cause
diabetes Grandison cells well you get
improvements in some of these things
there are many ways of targeting
fundamental aging processes now there
are at least you know they're they're
well over a couple of dozen drugs now
the target fundamental aging processes
in mice and there are many more coming
the question will be can we say in an
older person who's got five different
medical conditions can we improve
slightly three out of five of those
conditions with a single
why is slowing or stopping aging a goal
why is it a goal well I can answer that
in two words why not I mean if we can
live healthy longer that's just a pure
good and extending health span and
extending lifespan are correlated so
even if we say our goal is extending
health span that will very likely at
least in the early years extend overall
lifespan and anybody who's been at the
the deathbed of a loved one or a child
or a parent and asked us that question
why can't we have more time I think that
if we can do that if we can what's the
those the purpose of health care it's
alleviating suffering and one of the
failures of all the miraculous work
that's been done an extending lifespan
is that we have more and more people who
are in in in miserable conditions in
geriatric centers or wherever but if we
can have people live longer healthier
lives that's in my mind just a pure good
you're born and we have all these
rituals and we when people talk about
death I would imagine most people in
this room you say what's the purpose of
death and many people would say oh it
gives meaning to life but would you like
to have so much meaning in your life
that knowing that you're gonna die two
days from next I would really focus your
love of your of your life and the answer
would be no so we have all of these
rituals and we think about death and we
have all these words that we say but if
any of us had an individual choice of
getting ten healthy years with a parent
more healthy years with a parent or a
child I think everybody would take it
I've noticed that many cultures have
different ways of categorizing and and
surrounding the notion of death and
putting it somewhere safe people who
focus on death who are not trained to do
so can get very depressed and it can
increase suicide rates in fact so is
there anything isn't there something
good about having ways to put it off in
a in a safe place and Joe you deal with
well there's this great book by Ernest
Becker from 70s called the denial look
yes right and it reminds me of what what
a European colleague of mine once said
about Americans he says they don't die
they just underachieve we are a
fundamentally death-denying culture and
and I think that there's you know I
think no one is against this in a kind
of medical way to kind of compress
morbidity and and decrease the burden of
living with chronic disease but I think
there's a there's a fundamental you know
illusion of control here that we're not
gonna get rid of death you know it will
eventually catch up with us you know
death and taxes and I think it is part
of the human fabric and frankly I think
that the fact that we will die gives us
some meaning to take seriously the time
that we have because it's not it's not
an unlimited gift we want it to be a
little brighter and shinier but it's not
unlimited and I think it we haven't been
sold that it is who we are
immortality as part of our all right
yeah I agree I don't think anybody here
is think I don't think immortality other
than downloadable brains which may or
may not happen is what anybody's talking
about I think that if we can extend
healthy lifespan but let's listen for a
moment
America especially what is this about
American life that has made us it's
extreme individualism okay almost the
kind of libertarianism control control
and and in fact the people who seek say
assisted suicide in say Oregon it's not
pain its wanting to be in control in the
timing and manner of their death
everybody thought it was going pain and
symptom management it's an existential
crisis and it's the fundamental loss of
control and I would say that this is
this this effort here is part of that
same social urge to have you know
controlled dominion over one's life
one's death and how long one lives but
from a psychological point of view
you've got new ways of describing to us
when it becomes unhealthy to deny it
right I think I think when we see this
you know in in clinical life where
people are asking for care that at this
day and age is impossible
and we you know medical issues of
medical futility interestingly the word
futility comes from the Latin if you
tillis which means a leaky sieve you
know it no longer serves its purpose it
doesn't hold the fluid and and you know
it's it's amazing how we we we seek to
expand extend life and people just can't
accept the finality of it and and it
leads to tremendous grief and so you
know I think we have to be less
dichotomous about this and and and
appreciate that there's a benefit here
and compressing morbidity but we're
never going to get rid of our mortality
I think we have to talk that continue to
talk though about quality that's because
right because a number of the medical
devices that exist at least in the
cardiovascular field there are a lot of
people who would say yes I want a device
and I want to live longer and they get
that device and they realize the quality
of their life it's not as good as they
thought it was going to be and all of a
sudden the conversation changes and I
think we have to be able and willing to
discuss quality and I mean you see your
this is what you do you don't you deal
with people who have have quality issues
all the time yes as of geriatrician what
I see is of what people fear the most is
loss of Independence and control and you
know myself and my colleagues and
geriatrics we're sick of providing
better wheelchairs walkers and
incontinent places so finally the
biology of Aging in the last you know
since around 2009 has moved very quickly
to developing interventions where we
might be able to enhance health spend
even if it's a few months or a couple of
years or something like that it would
probably add a lot more in some ways
arguably than curing heart attacks
because if you cure off if you cure
heart attacks you're choosing instead to
die as I mentioned before of Alzheimer's
or some horrible cancer because these
conditions cluster so our goal is to
figure out a way to delay these things
as a group even if it's a small amount
and to try to compress morbidity and
these are potentially achievable goals
over the next decade because we can do
now in mice and and other lower
mammalian species and the question is
can we get this to people in an
incremental way in a safe way where
we're dealing with targeting multiple
conditions at once instead of one at a
time and that's a really important issue
because right now we have a fundamental
problem of the misallocation of
resources we're doing what Jim called
the whack-a-mole I mean this somebody
has cancer you go after the cancer then
they have cardiovascular disease we go
after that but if one thing if we
eliminated all of these diseases even
then people wouldn't live that much
longer but if you get rid of one get rid
of all cancer in the world it's about
3.3 years extended lifespan and so the
question is why are we spending so much
on the diseases of Aging and so little
on understanding and targeting aging
itself and if we just main risk factor
yeah exactly exactly stream clause
exactly yeah so right now and every one
of these diseases are they're all
terrible and they all have pressure
groups and they all have an
infrastructure for cancer cardiovascular
disease dementia whatever and what needs
to happen at least in my view I think
some people up here would show this view
is we just need to shift some of that
spending into understanding the basic
science of aging because from an
evolutionary perspective we all
everybody has this sense of what is and
isn't natural but the things that we
think of as being natural actually
aren't natural at all it's not natural
that we live to 80 just that our
ancestors didn't do it that's just this
one just a period of time there's
nothing about evolution that has decided
that we live 280 because frankly
evolution could care less how long we
live if if babies are getting eaten by
Tigers babies would grow armor if
parents were getting eaten by Tigers
they couldn't raise their babies babies
would become more independent like
Komodo dragons do but if an old person
got eaten by lion it was bad for the old
person but it didn't really touch our
evolution as a species so there's
there's a lot of fluidity in how how
we're going to be able to age how we're
going to be in my view how are going to
be able to impact and target the
mechanisms of aging and animal models
are showing as you guys has been
mentioned that there are a lot of things
that that can be done I think should be
done but I want to speak
about animal models I feel really
strongly about this we can cure anything
in mice we can cure cancer in mice we
can fear aging in mice which are heart
disease in mice but we can't cure any of
it people and that's because those
animal models are healthy until we give
them a heart attack mmm or they're
healthy until we do whatever we don't
have models so let us look at old sick
taking all these drugs also have cancer
also have all these other things models
where we have to test these things so I
think part of really figuring out how
these work is testing them in real-life
situations and I think it's important to
understand women live longer again this
varies across species to the gender
differences so yeah female mice don't
outlive male mice they do if they have
heart disease it's very situation
dependent and generally female mice have
the same life span as male mice in
others some other species males outlive
females for example in some birds so
this varies and is peculiarities what
one thing that does seem to be fairly
constant are some of these fundamental
aging processes from yeast through worms
through flies through mice unlike
something like Alzheimer's disease which
is a uniquely human disease or unlike
atherosclerosis which is almost uniquely
him and does occur in some other species
Adrian
fundamental aging processes tend to
occur across species so there's some
hope and I think we have to have a lot
of skepticism as you're saying until we
do clinical trials there's some hope
that they might be translatable but as
you're saying we have to do the clinical
trials and we have to show this in
people because you know showing things
in mice or or rats or dogs or monkeys
doesn't necessarily translate let me see
if I can get my aging brain to summarize
what we've generally been saying so far
you're saying that more than going after
individual diseases go after Aging yes
that's what you're all saying yes what
is what is the future is is this
regenerative medicine or is it is it a
new kind of medicine
it's what
I think it depends on what you're trying
what you're trying to do if if you walk
in the door and your legs you you've cut
off your leg at the knee and you're
bleeding everywhere obviously you have
to deal with that first before you can
think about how old you are and what you
got to do and I think I think some of
the disease states that we've been
talking about heart disease that you
know other chronic diseases we have to
get under control and as we develop new
hypotheses about aging and understand
aging
command think there are two things I
think this Falls generally under the
rubric of prevention right right but
it's a kind of secondary prevention
after the you know the process has
already begun people who were you know
when their 40s may not have had a heart
to heart attack but they may have a
thorough sclerotic changes and could you
reverse that's for some you know
anti-aging intervention versus an
earlier public health intervention that
that changes the built environment puts
calorie counts on the food teaches
people about about you know the high-fat
diet so I think I think it's important
to realize the built environment has a
lot to do with the the the process of
aging some of its going to be genetic
some it's going to be environmental but
this is all under the rubric of a kind
of prevention and I would hate for
people to think they could they could
live whatever life they wanted to live
and then when they're 45 they could go
check into the anti-aging clinic and get
some kind of magic bullet when in fact
it's better to have a kind of a
multi-faceted approach to preventing the
morbidity that that's down downstream
what's the biggest intervention that I
can do right now because I really want
to live as long as possible
it's all of these things you need to eat
healthy you should exercise 45 minutes a
day
don't smoke there's a lot of work on
what they call blue zones which are part
of the world where people live longer
and and Dan Buettner and others went and
said well what did what do they all have
in common and is that everybody had had
physical activity built into their lives
they were in communities they had a
sense of common purpose and for whatever
reason they ate they all seemed to eat a
lot of beans but having said that and so
everybody should do all of those things
but it's also true that in some
of the metformin studies for example
they had the two groups of mice one were
the mice that ate crap and did an
exercise and one were the mice that that
ate good food and exercise then they
gave metformin
to the non exercising lazy fat mice and
they outlived the healthy mice so I
think that you should do all of those
things but then there will also be very
likely be in my view some other types of
interventions that you'll be better off
had you lived a virtuous life but will
help everybody and it'll feel like
you're living for 7,000 years if you're
only living a virtuous life right boy
some of us enjoy it some some of these
interventions will see their first light
in early clinical trials in roughly a
half dozen areas and some of these
trials are underway at the moment so one
of the areas is going to be looking at
multi morbidity so if you've got an 85
year old who's got five or six different
conditions can you partially alleviate
three of those conditions with a single
agent so that's one approach the second
is going to be in conditions where there
are accelerated aging like States so
trials are beginning in people who've
had bone-marrow transplants who've had
massive doses of chemotherapy and
acquire this accelerated aging like
state in three to five years or the kids
with progeria is that who look old when
they're when they're young another area
is going to be where there are localized
accumulations of changes that are
associated with aging like States for
example pulmonary fibrosis idiopathic
pulmonary fibrosis which is normally
fatal without a lung transplant again we
at Mayo recently published a paper
showing that these drugs that clear
senescence cells radically improve mice
in that particular model and clinical
trials are going to begin on humans yes
how soon very soon will these kinds of
drugs reduce the amount of chemotherapy
that has to be given or reduced side
effects of chemotherapy or enhanced
recovery after surgery or enhance
recovery after pneumonia will they and
some of them do this now one trials
already been done showing that we can
improve vaccine response in elderly
individuals to flu vaccine by giving
these kinds of drugs in the
case a drug related to something called
rapamycin for a few days two weeks
before they get their flu shot and these
were community living healthy elderly
individuals who normally a bad response
to flu vaccine it was greatly improved
by targeting fundamental aging processes
so there are a bunch of clinical trial
scenarios that have been gamed out over
a three-year period
by a large group of Aging centers across
the country and involving Europe that
included the NIH and the FDA and so
there there are very short-term trials
that could be done in a short period of
time with subjects involved in the
trials for two to six months to look at
these kinds of interventions and see if
they work and those trials are beginning
well this comes to the next question I
wanted to ask about is have all of you
give us a sense of what the next 20 or
30 years in this field looked like where
are we going well I'm the only science
fiction writer here so I'm I feel the
freest just to make stuff up which I
which I will do so I think in the near
term I'll maybe I'll do it in three
buckets in the near term all of the kind
of work that we've mentioned to this
point I think some of that will bear
fruit some of it seems very promising
now and it turns out it won't work but
there will be a lot of things whether
it's rejuvenating stem cells or pruning
senescence cells or using blood plasma
transfusion to trigger certain cellular
responses or all kinds of small
molecules I mean a lot of these things
that are undergoing some of them will be
realized that's the the short term in
the medium to longer term I think things
are going to get more it's gonna be more
maybe ethically challenging and the
kinds of things which people I think
everything about these interventions my
guess is most of you in the audience
will say well that's pretty good if I'm
aging and you can do this kind of
intervention but in the media in the
medium term we're going to use genome
sequencing and we're going to understand
different genetic combinations that give
you a greater shot of living longer and
I've written a book on the future of
human genetic engineering and embryo
selection but I think that
there will come a time in a not so
distant future when all children the
majority of children will be born
through IVF and those embryos will be
screened and they will be screened for
certain outcomes and your possibility of
living a long and healthy and robust
life will be one of those outcomes that
will be screened for at the time when
decisions are being made about which
embryos early stage embryos to be
implanted in the mother that would I
would think that is the medium term and
the longer term if we're talking
hundreds of years and again I'm the
science fiction writer so take this with
a grain of salt if we do get to the
point of downloadable memory and we can
transfer the way our minds into some
other medium then we'll just have this
fundamental question is that us so if
somebody has today has locked-in
syndrome and the only way that they can
communicate is with their eyes you would
say well is that a person I think the
aunt that everybody would say the answer
to that is yes but if you said if you
transferred that person's brain into a
functioning robot and now that person
could walk and speak and do all of those
things that they couldn't do when they
had locked-in syndrome is that the same
person it's a it's an ethical question
but at some point that may be the kind
of if we're really talking about
immortality that may be the question
we're asking of potential red flags
going up in the back of my brain good
yeah and in the front of Joe's well you
know I think let's start in the
short-term I think you know the history
medicine is littered you know with with
with more failure than success and so
you know the the classic immortal cell
is a cancer cell okay that doesn't stop
dividing so I think that the risk of
iatrogenic sis and doing harm premium no
no tray above all else do you no harm
should be probably at the forefront I
think the skepticism about translating
from animals to humans is indicative of
that concern you know a longer term I
think that that they're they're issues
of this social disruption you know
changes in the and longevity health
disparities I think are a really big
issue there's there's a concern about
about
you know changing expectations the
science getting ahead of social norms
social constructs and this would be a
classic story that we do all the time we
we have a scientific advance and then
we're trying to catch up with it you
know we have a hard time with genetic
testing and I'm worried about sort of
the eugenic you know flavor of selecting
embryos I think we're you know we're
strengthened by our diversity and there
are many people in this room or probably
heterozygote for something bad I would
say everybody in this room is
heterozygous have a good gene and a bad
gene you know so we were selecting for
for that for the good genes a lot of
good people will be left out and I think
that that really worries me and that
hasn't worked out too well in history so
you know and again last point in all
these people is quite an enhancement
people who are in favor of enhancement
the philosophers some of whom are mostly
in Oxford you know are the people who
need to be enhanced the ones who are
going to decide how we're going to be
enhanced again it's the humans so I'm
very concerned I have no trouble with
with the medical you know utility
compressing morbidity and improving the
health span I think that's all terrific
but I start worrying about us
engineering our future as a species in a
way that's incredibly disrupt and this
comes into the field of new
understanding of Neil post neo-darwinian
is the old view which was not Darwin's
was that it was just simply random
mutations and struggling for the
survival of the fittest and red in tooth
and claw the new view I understand from
what I've been reading lately is much
more complex that we are a species that
gets ahead not just by having winners
and losers but by cooperating and that a
lot of cooperation and sharing may be
what makes us less plus epigenetic
factors that are environmental factors
which are not in heritable right so so
the mark was right right characteristics
can be inherited so this leads to a very
difficult well I'm glad you used the
word eugenics because we should be
reminded eugenics was very popular in
America in the tens and 20s and 30s and
when they were sterilizing people who
seemed to be imbeciles and a lot of that
was going on
legally eventually became illegal but
people who liked it went over and joined
Hitler's groups who carried out
experiments announcements for example
yeah but I think the science is
advancing and the science it's not
coincidental that what Jim was talking
about the big advances over the last
decade we are at an inflection point in
our science and we are at an inflection
point in our evolution as a species and
so for four billion years our ancestors
have evolved by the forces that you've
that you've mentioned but right now our
science is beginning a process and of
allowing us to guide our own
evolutionary path and what being
thinkers have been saying that for four
centuries and yes but our tools are so
much more than that and they're getting
more advanced and so but we will still
have the same but and people who were in
power and the people who are making
those decisions have not necessarily
more advanced that's a hundred percent
correct in fact we're in a
post-enlightenment age we are we are
heading we don't run fast I don't
believe in size
I completely agree I completely agree
with it and yet the science is advancing
exponentially and so the onus that's why
these kinds of conversations are so
important is the onus is on all of us
right because you can either stop the
science and let's say you stop it here
it's gonna happen someplace else or you
can say well we better really get our
act together and if we value diversity
right let's have a conversation about
diversity in the 90s I was doing stem
cell research when when then President
Bush said we're going to we're going to
eliminate embryonic stem cell research
and I remember getting called by the
media and I asked how I felt about that
and I basically said the problem is if
we're only going to use the established
cell lines there were all established
from retreat people who could afford in
vitro fertilization guess what they're
only really about 12 of those that are
good so we're gonna make all our
decisions about stem cells going forward
based on 12 rich white people that
scares me because diversity is what we
need to understand biology if you look
at every one of just us who aren't that
diverse we're gonna be different another
another another axis of diversity is
people who have disabilities I couldn't
agree more about diversity diversity is
our sole survival strategy as a species
and has been from the from the beginning
so if we lose if whatever people think
is good it's good now it won't be in in
the future and we these ethical
questions that's the ëthe the essence of
the debate that everybody needs to be
part of this is not a debate for experts
it's not even a debate for just one from
one day or one weekend I mean these are
the questions the the fundamental
questions about the future of our
species and that's that should be the
top of everybody's minds but we can't
close our eyes to where this technology
is heading because again we could shut
this down in the United States it will
be good or bad whatever your your views
are for the United States but it won't
have any impact whatsoever on the
advance of this technology reproductive
cloning happens the fact that CRISPR
technologies that you've all heard about
or you can you can actually you can
actually edit someone's genes in real
life says and it is happening in humans
outside the US now is something we all
want to be discussing and what we well
whether we embrace that or don't yeah
and if you had a time machine and you
end hundreds into the future and people
were saying oh we have this thing it's
made of code the code is writable it's
readable attackable you know you say oh
yeah i got you it's computer code and
they'd like look at you like you're
crazy no it's biology it's biology so we
are we are developing the tools to write
and rewrite the code of life we may be
wise or not wise in those applications
but we will have those tools and forgive
me for asking this question but we're
talking about people who are lucky
enough to know about all of this
do you think it will be something that
can be spread to all humans everywhere
without a lot of the expense eventually
well eventually I'm gonna leave a lot of
humans just dying in terrible health I
think again it depends on what our
values are right now we have all of the
food to feed everybody on earth so we
have the clothing to clothe everybody on
earth we choose not to do so if we
maintain the bad values that we
collectively have now that will will be
the case but there is there are
financial incentives because eliminating
as Jim was saying if we can eliminate or
reduce the occurrence of these
comorbidities associated with aging
that's going to be a huge amount of
savings if people are living healthy
hundred year lives and then and then
dying relatively quickly and that's
going to free a lot of resources they
can be invested in all sorts of things
there's a phenomenon there there are
people who are what we call super
centenarians these are people who live
to a very advanced age this tends to be
inherited in families and one of the
interesting things about these people
who are dying at 100 and 510 is that
when you look at large numbers of them
they live very very healthy and
independent and they tend to be dead
within six months of their first visit
to a doctor so they die very quickly we
also notice this and experimental
animals that are treated with some of
these kinds of interventions or worse a
single gene mutations have been used
that that have an effect on on lifespan
there are also some data from about 20
years ago that came from studies of
health utilization that the last two
years of life are the most expensive
there are three the last two years of
life of a person who dies at 70 costs
three times the last two years of life
of someone who dies at 100 and that may
in part be because of this rectangular
ization of morbidity so I've got a
shorter term view of some of this I've
got patients here now my my view is
I want to extend their health span and
delay the onset of these diseases and
it's turning out now that these
interventions will actually treat some
of these diseases once they're
established including frailty starting
interrupts health span you've used a
certain price a lovely phrase health
span as opposed to lifespan yes so
health span is a period during life when
people are living independently free of
pain free of disability you know
basically able to do what they what they
want to do so the goal of the field as
far as I can read it from my vantage
point is that we want to improve health
span and if life span is increased
that's a side effect so a question about
the fact that these things have to run
in families parents grandparents going
back that way but is it necessarily
something that runs in families because
it's passed down genetically or
genetically and epigenetically or both
of those plus culturally and there's
something about the lifestyle this has
been noted across populations in in
different countries and I'm talking
about people who live beyond way beyond
100 so there are several trials looking
at these kinds of populations going on
around the world there's a high
heritable component but it's not
everything so of course they're going to
be at the genetic and and social and
other kinds of factors involved but some
of the genetic changes that account for
or contribute to this increased
longevity within families are beginning
to be worked out they're about a dozen
dozen polymorphisms we call them that
have been found so far and they make
sense because they follow the same
pathways as food restriction which
extends lifespan in many species and
they contain the targets of these kinds
of drugs that are being developed that
affect lifespan so that sounds hopefully
eventually you may be able to get to
understand this well enough to be able
to spread the knowledge to everybody on
the idea and as I as we were talking
about before some of the early drugs
that may have an effect and don't take
these drugs don't take that we haven't
done
Charles yeah yeah don't take these drugs
we're all taking their paper out it
happens every time yeah but he says
where do I get it what's the don't don't
don't do it
but some of them are very very cheap
like metformin right you're talking
about before two to five cents a pill so
if we are able and in the next iteration
after we do these short-term kinds of
studies and look at individual
indications and see if they in aggregate
line up with the possibility we're
targeting fundamental aging processes we
may move to a kind of preventive
strategy and if that happened to work if
that happened to work it would by by
projections that have been done by a
variety of groups reduce health care
costs enough that the intervention
itself would be relatively much cheaper
for any society could I just maybe you
guys could just talk a little bit about
the role of inflammation in aging
because I think that that would be
really interesting to kind of get on the
table
well chronic what we call sterile that
is in the absence of bacteria or viruses
low-grade inflammation is something that
you find in many tissues and at sites of
age-related disease so this is where
immune cells go in that release factors
that cause dysfunction senescence alls
act in part by producing a lot of
inflammatory factors I'd also attract
cells from the immune system and and
these these kinds of factors will also
poison stem and progenitor cells and
cause them to dysfunction and can
contribute to macromolecular dysfunction
problems with DNA and proteins so all
these things are sort of interlinked but
this kind of inflammation is a very
special inflammation it's not the kind
of inflammation you would treat with a
nonsteroidal anti-inflammatory drug or
with aspirin
although aspirin does in mice and
related drugs drug salsa late does of
some effect on on median lifespan at
least in lower mammals what we're
talking about is inflammation that's
much more specific and of a particular
type and metformin is one of the dresses
market that kind of inflammation
rapamycin is another one that does it so
these are these are inflammatory
mediators produced by senescent cells
something call the senescence
associated secretory phenotype long word
we called this mess and that Foreman
acts in part by targeting that pathway
doors so I want to I want to speak to
that though because I my worldview is
slightly different which is that in
flick ute inflammation is a good thing
acute inflammation is when an injury
occurs and basically your body is
producing a signal saying hey there's an
injury and and I need repair whatever
that repair happens to be and I happen
to believe part of that is he cells that
you recruit and they're not all stem and
progenitor cells so my permian cells so
you get those cells they're a number of
years ago we started look but and if you
get those cells there you turn off the
inflammation if you don't your body
ramps up inflammation and I think it's
like your body saying I said I've got an
injury send me cells and you start
recruiting the wrong cells and getting a
secondary pro-inflammatory effect and a
number of years ago we started when
people started doing stem cell therapy
trials that were primarily bone marrow
derived stem cells and many of you may
have heard you get bone marrow from your
hip you take the cells and you give them
and you're giving stem cells well only
3% of the cells in our bone marrow or
stem cells the other 97% are not stem
cells they're immune cells or other
types of cells that are going to give
rise to blood cells or etc and when we
started measuring those and said which
cells that are present associate with
repair guess what when the stem cells
lose the immune cells
so there's a whole response to
inflammation that is I mean stem cells
and the cells we give turned out
inflammation reproducibly acute
inflammation is great
two questions from the audience but I
want to ask one question is it possible
that that death has an advantage for the
evolution of the species because it
means the young have to take over at a
more frequent rate there are some
situations where that's true there to
use technical terms there are three
kinds of late life history one of them
is no no senescence basically are no
sort of classic biological aging another
is what we call Cemil parity that means
giving birth once and another is it or
parity that means giving birth multiple
times so in some plants and some animals
if you do the right things if
evolutionarily or the environment
changes the right way you will find
individuals died upon reproduction so
dandelions do this a lot of annual
plants Pacific salmon species do this
where the where the rainbow trout which
is actually a salmon doesn't and so very
quickly in evolutionary terms you can
turn a species from being iteroparous
that is giving birth multiple times and
then having a senescent phase and dying
to dying upon reproduction and you do
that one of the ways you can do that in
fruit flies which normally are what we
call it or Paris you can make them
semelparous and forced evolutionary
experiments in the laboratory by
restricting their food so there's an
advantage to having post-reproductive
individuals die very quickly under that
special circumstance and you can find a
cause of death for example in the salmon
they get massive production of
corticosteroids from their adrenal
glands which kills them after they start
after they spawn of the pond going up a
stream you remove their gonads and their
adrenals and they'll live 25 years
instead of two to four years so it can
happen so this raises this sort of gives
us new framework to think about where we
may be going with the science that you
all are specialists in if we if you're
giving us as humans the choice about
what we want to make our particularly
span we might choose to what to have
necessarily a younger generation take
over every hundred and fifty years yeah
what two points on that one just to
follow up on Jim's very interesting
point um if you want to live longer
eunuchs
live longer than non eunuchs women who
get pregnant one two or three times
actually live long beyond three times
mortality goes up
it's a j-shaped curve for for more
talent yeah and I'd like to put in a
plug for wisdom we look at there was
some recent research about killer whales
where they found out that it was the
oldest woman in the pod was the leader
because she had she had all of this
information that it had been stored up
over the years so if we have a thing
where people are living longer then
that's great if we have a social issue
of tenure or whatever let's solve for
that issue but it but it's like how much
investment goes into every human a
lifetime of experience and knowledge and
if we could unleash that capacity of all
these older people who now are having
dementia they can't communicate and they
can share and we find a structure that
allows us to have back to the blue zone
though it was community yeah they're
associated to the greatest degree with
longevity all right questions there are
some futurists who think that the
singularity is near namely that we are
approaching a stage where AI artificial
intelligence is going to take over
they'll become more evolved and we are
and some of them Ray Kurzweil for
example you know think that that is
really near so it is possible that
biological intelligence is a relatively
short-lived phase in the life of
civilizations - only to be taken over by
some form of AI let me be the first to
respond to that just because like I said
I'm a science fiction writer and my last
book eternal sonata has a blurb from Ray
Kurzweil on the cover and but what he
means by singularity is just that
machines become self-replicating and so
that doesn't necessarily mean that the
machines will take over it just depends
on what the code says so we better write
that code carefully but
yeah yeah I'm so it's so but but we will
for sure our biological evolution is a
Waystation in our overall evolution we
will co-evolved with our we are already
co-evolved in with our technology we
will continue to co-evolved and we will
become a hybrid species that doesn't
mean we won't have values that doesn't
mean we won't be asking these ethical
questions but we are going to have to do
it in the context of a changing world
that will be very much but not entirely
driven by technology question if you
have heart disease maybe you could
change your heart or maybe you could
change your kidneys but I could see a
limitation related with your brain
because I could see they say cells in
your brain are different you can you can
print generate these cells yes so you
know like when you have when you are 62
years old or this age the cognitive
process it started to go down so if we
seem their future about in mortality
brain is a burden so what is happening
right now nowadays how do you cool in
the future improve your brain
these drugs are improving cognitive
function at old mice it's the same story
different target organ you know it it's
all there all all of our organs are
affected or brain just the consequences
are different and there's been cognitive
enhancement using brain stimulation in
Parkinson's disease and some patients as
well so for traumatic brain injury and
stroke yeah we haven't talked about para
biases but they have these things have
been people have been doing for hundreds
of years actually where you get an old
mice old mouse in a young mouse you cut
them open and stitch them together and
then after over time the old mouse
becomes young in many ways and the young
mouse becomes old in many ways and it's
skin it's muscle but also when sadly for
these mice it's not pleasant but when
they biopsy their brains the young the
old mice as brains have become in many
ways younger so so pregnancy is the
ultimate para bioessence
and that's part of why we think that
there's a benefit for the few
pregnancies because you share all of
those things but then over time the
stress of pregnancy it wins and it's a
thing we all kind of makes sense
intuitively to people that you are like
an adult and you can have a baby but
it's when you think about it's like
that's really weird like I'm whatever 30
years old and then you've created a
thing that's and that's why and that's
why women whose immune systems have to
be different and inflammation that's
different if we of meiosis right that re
scrambles the - yeah and it's not
so we have that capacity within
ourselves alright this might be for Jim
but uh there's a lot of impressive
research going on in terms of
regeneration of tissue and organs but I
was wondering you know is there the
population just predisposed to have a
certain percentage of people with
Alzheimer's what's being done for the
old gray matter and the brain in terms
of extending the quality of life well
funding for Alzheimer's research has
taken off recently that that is an area
where there's been a considerable
injection of funding and the area is
becoming I mean under the surface
there's a lot more progress being made
than people I think realize that should
hit there there's some very interesting
clinical trials one of the which
there'll be some results from next year
so that field is moving faster than I
think the public realizes we have to
bear in mind that the brain is part of
the body it's not a separate thing and
so some of these processes that affect
other organs or have general systemic
effects are also going to affect
predisposition to Alzheimer's and
related disorders I think a lot could
happen soon so to circle back to kind of
what we opened with talking about where
the last hundred years has gone in terms
of age what is the community or even
individually your personal opinions
where the next hundred years will leave
us or you know what do you guys
expect the numbers to increase two
panelists my sense is that that tools
are going to get more tools are going to
get cheaper hopefully we're gonna
disseminate things more broadly and the
ethics are gonna have to come in to it
Jim I think once you go beyond five-year
predictions you start getting into muddy
water by ten years you're often wrong by
20 years predictions you're just about
always wrong so I hate to think of
making predictions about what will
happen a hundred years from now making
predictions if I have a hundred years
now so I will take a swing at it so over
the last hundred years average lifespan
has has extended by three months per
year so if let's just say we keep that
going for another hundred years then
that's plus 25 years of average life
expectancy I think again we look at the
exponential increase of all of these
technologies with biology becoming
information technology in a hundred
years the amount of change between now
and a hundred years from now will be 50
60 hundred times more than the change
over the last hundred years and that's
only going to get faster so I again I
can't say specifically what's going to
happen but we are going to see life and
biology and a lot of things very
differently in a hundred years also be
cautious of is scaling so although we
can increase a mouse is a life span in
mice by 75 or 80 percent that translates
into a certain number of months you know
when and if we go to people would we
would we have an effect on life or
health spend that would be a 75 or 80
percent increase or would it be a ten
month increase so there are a lot of
scaling issues go online and look at a
medical journal from 1917 and read how
confidently they thought that their new
innovations what they were going to do
for for our generation and I think with
that that
retrospective does is gives us should
give us all sense of humility great
encouragement about the promise of this
work but going forward with a sense of
humility about the mystery and the
complexity of this biology that we're
just beginning to unpack yeah when you
compare the whole suite of technologies
available now to a hundred years ago
it's unimaginable and so I think if you
100 years for 100 years from now they'll
be a panel just like this just like you
will be having the same is gonna be
plugged into the cloud to have all kinds
of super intelligent
so what that argues is technology
continues to increase like yes biology
is kind of a lot slower but I think but
I think those trend lines are going to
merge that we're going to turn as I
mentioned before our biology into a form
of IT and then all bets are off well I'd
like to acknowledge we've had an
astonishingly great panel with a great
depth of knowledge and experience
[Applause]
[Music]